the movie is set in 1952 during the
deadly Korean War at the start we see a
group of famous Chinese snipers called
the fifth Squad wandering around a snowy
hill they are known for their accuracy
resilience and dedication to work we get
to know that they are on the hunt for
American enemies as the squad leader Liu
takes out his binoculars and tracks some
of them after a while he assigns each
Squad member's specific enemies to shoot
as this will lead to an effective
execution obliging to the order the
soldiers take their positions and start
firing at their specified Targets in a
matter of seconds it appears as though
everyone is dead but soon one American
Rises up implying that a member of the
fifth Squad missed their shot don't feel
bad they're Americans so they've
probably got plot armor Liu targets the
enemy but to his surprise the man gets
on the back of his truck and opens fire
with the machine gun the squad quickly
disperses and lays down while Liu rolls
sideways to avoid getting shot then he
points his sniper at the enemy and
finishes him off with a clean shot
through the head this makes all of his
team members stare at him in awe guess
it wasn't Bradley Cooper after all
elsewhere a group of American soldiers
are seen in their Barracks ready to roll
out their Superior Captain Williams
approaches them and asks who gave them
the order to head off he then finds out
that a soldier named John has been sent
by Congress to track Leah's fifth Squad
it turns out that Jon is keeping two of
the fifth Squad intelligence agents
hostage for his plan to take down Liu
Captain Williams however is not
satisfied with this and thinks that Jon
is in it for the fame on a cold morning
the fifth Squad is seen in their
Barracks talking while sipping on hot
bowls of soup shortly after Liu arrives
and informs them of their new Mission
they have just found out that two of
their intelligence agents have been
ambushed so they will have to head to
the valley where the Ambush took place
and bring them back the soldiers
immediately get ready however Liu orders
one of them named dayong to stay back it
turns out that some reporters are coming
to interview Leo but as he is busy he
wants dayong to stay back and be
interviewed as he is the only one in the
group who is educated the latter wants
to head to the war zone and rescue his
friends but he also cannot go against
the orders of his captain shortly after
the reporters arrive and they asked
dayong several questions about the fifth
Squad and specifically Liu however
dayong replies by expressing his
disappointment in not being involved in
the new Mission this is specifically
because his best friend Liang is also an
intelligence agent who has been missing
for weeks presumably captured by the
Americans unable to continue with the
interview anymore dayang approaches his
other subordinate and begs to be let go
so he can join the gang feeling sympathy
the kind subordinate promptly agrees and
sets him off a few hours later dayong
finally manages to catch up with the
fifth Squad Liu is unhappy to see him
there but nonetheless he doesn't say
anything and keeps marching shortly
after they reach the valley and from
afar Liu uses his binoculars and spots
two bodies on the ground he identifies
one of them as Liang he then orders the
squad to move on ahead while he's stays
behind on the lookout despite the
obvious danger a few soldiers risk their
lives and start carrying the bodies
unfortunately while they are at it Liu
notices light reflecting From The
Trenches realizing that they have fallen
into a trap he yells at the squad to get
down but it's too late the Americans
opened fire and kill three members of
the fifth Squad while the others run and
take cover ye one of the surviving
members notices his friend Bleeding Out
profusely and decides to assist him
Captain Liu denies him permission but ye
has already made up his mind dayong
hurls a first aid kid in his Direction
but unfortunately before ye can get to
it he is shot and killed the assailant
is none other than the new American
Soldier John that douche who's just in
it for the babes a few minutes later Liu
devises a strategy so that he can move
closer to the rest of the squad he
instructs three of them to lay down
suppressing fire on the enemy location
while Dion will use a spoon to locate
their exact whereabouts soon both sides
begin pelting each other with bullets
and taking advantage of the opportunity
diong finds out where the enemies are
located with this information Captain
Liu uses his impeccable sniping skills
to take down one of the enemies
subsequently he runs over to dayong and
yells at him violently blaming him for
Yee's death just then a Korean boy named
Yuan makes his way into the battlefield
he starts dragging the unconscious
liang's body prompting both Jon and Liu
to open fire near him to catch his
attention moments later the enemies lure
you on and take a hold of him meanwhile
the fifth Squad comes up with a strategy
to obtain the agent's bodies while the
enemies are distracted with Yuan one
member of the squad
chubby finds a large metal shield and
decides to use it on his back which is
attached to a rope that the group holds
Jon and the other enemies start shooting
at him but chubby remains unharmed
unfortunately the Rope snaps and he is
forced to use both his hands to hold the
shield the Americans easily Target his
hands and then his head killing him
brutally oh chubby we barely knew you
buddy witnessing this the remaining
members of the fifth Squad are
devastated immediately afterwards the
little boy you won is released he
approaches liang's body and injects him
with adrenaline as per John's request
shockingly Liang opens his eyes leaving
the fifth Squad in utter disbelief it
turns out Yuan knows Liang as the
intelligence agents mostly linger around
the locals the two talk for a while
before the little boy leaves the
battlefield afterwards Liu puts together
a plan to take out the Americans one by
one two members of the squad begin to
dig the trench deeper to catch the
enemy's attention at the same time Liu
and Diane stay alert and name their
rifles towards the opposite trenches as
expected the Americans fall for their
ruse and fire at the digging shovels
giving dayong and Liu ample time to take
them out Furious Jon uses a machine gun
and shoots a bombshell where two members
of the fifth Squad are going to flank
this results in their immediate death
leaving only Captain Liu dyong and the
last member Leo alive at this point the
three have become somewhat hopeless but
since they are members of the fifth
Squad they decide to fight until the
last breath hence Lin and diong decide
to flank the enemies while leor stays
put on Lookout the two manage to outplay
an enemy troop and Liu shoots him in the
head killing him afterwards the fifth
Squad regroups and notices that the
adrenaline is wearing off on Liang as he
slowly becomes unconscious so they start
singing a patriotic song to keep them
awake and also probably to alert the
enemy to their location meanwhile one of
the enemy soldiers and John's Junior
Jack begins speaking over a loud
speakerphone in Chinese he wants to
negotiate with the fifth Squad by
sending Liang back to them in exchange
for Liu surprisingly Liu agrees without
any hesitation despite a huge
possibility that the deal may be a scam
he then drops his weapon and slowly
makes his way to the enemy base while
layor who's in charge of retrieving
Liang accompanies him from behind after
walking for a bit Liu stops and uses his
hands to signal that liang's body should
be sent back first before he goes on
further Jon agrees and so Leo starts
carrying the injured agent on his back
with this Liu also resumes his journey
to the enemy's base when suddenly Leora
is shot by an unknown Force which
startles them all enraged at the
Betrayal Liu pulls out a grenade and
Sprints towards the enemy base he
sacrifices himself as the grenade
explodes and torches the American base
killing a few enemies inside meanwhile
Leora is still alive but cannot move due
to his leg wound so Diane throws him a
rope and urges him to climb up along
with Liang on the other hand most of the
enemies are still alive but have
sustained injury series it is then
revealed that Captain Williams was the
one who called in the unexpected
shooting he contacts Jon and berates him
for letting Liang go as the latter is in
possession of some top secret classified
info after a while Captain William
arrives at the scene with a large number
of soldiers he wants to capture Liang
alive and force the information out of
him in the meantime Leo proceeds to wrap
the Rope around liang's unconscious body
John who is fed up with William's orders
picks up his rifle and shoots Leo in the
chest killing him that was fortunate for
me I didn't know how to pronounce that
guy's name this results in dayong being
the sole survivor of the fifth Squad and
now the rest of the mission is in his
hands suddenly Liang opens his eyes and
starts to unravel the bandages from his
body wound he notices Dion in the
distance and proceeds to write something
down on the bandages with his own blood
unfortunately Captain Williams spots the
act and figures out that Liang is trying
to pass the top secret Intel he orders
Jon to take action and the cunning
Soldier immediately shoots both of Lee
hands to stop him from writing terrified
by the incident Diane flees the
surrounding area while the enemy troops
move forward to capture a barely alive
Liang they then proceed to escort him to
their base for treatment but Liang
cleverly takes out a syringe and commits
the unthinkable with it dayong who is
witnessing all this from a new position
gets riled up and decides to rain hell
on the enemies he continuously shifts
his position and finishes off every
troop sent after Liang without missing a
shot or being discovered diong then
leaves the area and plans a strategy of
his own meanwhile Captain Williams
blames Jon for liang's death and yells
at him continuously this frustrates Jon
so much that he gets ready to shoot the
captain dead however at the last moment
he calms down and withdraws his weapon
after a while heavy artillery and
weapons finally reach the battlefield as
per Captain Williams's request they
immediately begin to fire mortars
targeting the hell where the last fifth
Squad member is hiding and completely
demolish it fortunately dayong is
already on the opposite side of the hill
and has a great angle on Captain
Williams he then takes the shot and his
bullet flies through the air eventually
hitting the captain in the head and
killing him this makes all the troops
Panic as dayong has outmaneuvered them
hence they defer to their senior John
for further orders fed up with the games
and wanting to finish the job by himself
Jon orders all the troops to retreat and
asks for a tank to be behind shortly
after the little boy Yuan again makes
his way into the valley looking for
Liang unfortunately for him he notices
his Soldier friend dead and starts
crying with yuan's sudden appearance an
idea strikes John's mind he and his
Junior Jack abduct the little boy and
drive off hoping they can force him to
give a fake statement in court martial
however dayong is still not done with
them so he rigs a bomb along the Tank's
tracks soon an explosion ensues and the
tank stops working inside Thick Smoke
begins to spread making it difficult for
the Americans to breathe despite this
they decide to stay inside and even
manage to spot from the bulletproof
glass John immediately loads up the tank
gun and starts shooting realizing the
danger dyong momentarily lays down and
shoots all of the bulletproof glass so
that the enemies can't see him anymore
however his plan fails miserably when
Jon manages to shoot him in the back
assuming that the last fifth Squad
member is finally dead Jack partially
opens the tank hatch to get a closer
look at him but right then diong
suddenly turns his body and shoots Jack
right in the head devastated by the loss
of his Junior John decides to end it
once and for all he read his two rifles
and then goes beneath the tank meanwhile
the wounded Dion crawls his way to a
nearby rock as he is bleeding he then
puts pressure on his wound with some
bandages and wraps it with his belt a
few moments later dyong throws a grenade
towards Jon but it falls extremely short
as Jon laughs at the failed attempt he
introduces himself and Praises dayong
for his impressive shooting skills he
also plants a decoy sniper between the
tank tires hoping he can fool Diane
however the latter is not going to
easily fall for it and instead he uses
the old spoon trick that Captain Liu had
taught him he eventually spots the
enemy's location and positions himself
in such a way that when Jon shoots at
the spoon he can immediately counter
fire the plan works and Jon momentarily
exposes himself while firing at the
spoon Dion takes full advantage of the
Split Second and takes his final shot
the bullet scrapes Jon's rifle and
passes straight through his head
finishing him off instantly nothing but
headshots for our boy dyang after the
final showdown he loots Jon's dead body
and finds a newspaper containing images
of Liu and the other members of the
fifth Squad Diane then enters the tank
and unties you on and makes a request
for candy it turns out that Liang was
able to successfully pass the message on
to dayong which read child candy on the
bandage the child is obviously you on
and on his hair there is a piece of
candy which was placed by Liang the
candy contains his small crumpled up
paper and after seeing this the two head
off home as they walk they meet a group
of soldier who has come to their rescue
the hyong passes on the Intel to his
senior which will help to receive the
ongoing conflict the movie ends with the
soldiers calling out the names of the
members of the fifth Squad implying that
their legacy will live on forever this
movie may have copied the ending of
Enemy at the gates but I'm gonna give it
a pass
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching